starwars the last Jedi guys it comes out
a matter of days
director Rian Johnson recently said
interview that he studied JJ Abrams
supports awakens quote forensic ly crime
scene you know you get it cuz crime
scene Johnson singled out the scene
showing rays force vision flashback
saying he studied it for clues for had
to continued this story in the last
should I now and about you guys but I've
been watching the Star Wars movies this
week in preparation including the force
awakens so I thought we could do the
same thing here re-examine that force
efficient scene to remind ourselves of
the cryptic detail speculate on what
they could mean and see if we learn
anything new what are you guys cool so
JJ Abrams stuck in a lot of mysterious
visuals and sound design in the sequence
so let's start out with the visuals so
just gonna recap here Rey snoops around
Mouse kanata's basement and finds Luke
Skywalker's lightsaber and the moon she
touches it she's transported to this
quarter now if you remember this is the
same quarter where Luke fought Darth
Vader in Cloud City in the Empire
Strikes Back thanks JJ concept art
actually for the force awakens suggested
that Rey was actually going to see that
dramatic end of Luke and Luke invaders
fight recreation then maybe another like
the HD quality of the movie oh maybe
yeah I was thinking you know in Harry
Potter how when the one's touched and
backfire oh the previous battles of the
Lost u saber I bet there's a big part of
that because as like everything that we
see here are connections with the
previous Jedi's who have wielded Jedi
who have wielded this weapon Jedi could
be plural or singular as we know that
people go crazy about
okay so this quarter twists and it caves
in and leaves rapist eyed Luke as he
kneels beside r2 and that shot was in
the force awakens teaser way way way
back when and new shots from the last
Jedi trailer make it looks like it looks
like Luke is witnessing the burning of a
Jedi Temple mm-hmm and in this sequence
in the wide shot of kylo surrounded by
bodies if you look closely when the
lightning strikes you can see the
silhouette of a what looks like that
temple it seems like yes this these are
the bodies of some odd ones I guess
there's they called the Knights of Ren
no no plastics they're called plastics
in me there were the bullies they know
when it's right when we see that she
might have been that's that's kind of
the the next mister here cuz we see ray
turns around she sees herself as a young
girl screaming after ship that left her
behind and he's at that bulbous hand
that's probably belonging to unkar plutt
the scrapyard owner back on jakku it's a
mystery why she would have been left
with him of course and why it seems like
right maybe he was caretaker of it was
she sold to him also if we are seeing
the point of view from where Luke was
was Luke teaching at the Jedi Temple and
then did Luke drop rey off vibes yeah
from like or protect him from her you
know we don't know if like if she's got
some powers and he doesn't want another
depends solo until Antichrist little 666
- he's gonna wake up in a cold sweat
tonight he's like I know
I'm at applause that you're able to do
that that would be amazing
okay what another interesting shot here
when Ray turns back to see that shuttle
that young ray is screaming that in the
Sun transforms into this red rectangle
right before it jumps to kylo Ren it's a
similar shape to the eyepiece of kylo
Ren's mass so it's suggesting maybe he
is watching her in this vision and then
of course she's transported to the snowy
forest of the Starkiller base a location
that she travels to later in the movie
the kylo jumps out so it's kind of like
we're seeing future and past all coming
together right so it seems like there's
influences going on here any yeah so
we've kind of made some observations do
you guys see anything else here that
like this was what what could happen I
like the idea of tapping into the
memories of the previous wielder or we
could be looking at premonitions from
furthest in the future to the most
recent so like maybe well cuz if the
last one was this she did run into kylo
Ren eventually after this she got
tortured and then she was in the forest
you guys and then maybe then leading
into that because she also was in some
like it cut to her looking at Luke I
believe when he's touching r2 so that
could be a memory or that could be
leading into the memory of all the
scenes that we've seen in the trailers
for last Jedi so far of her and like
lava land or fire forest wherever you
know classic Jedi places yeah yeah
something like that maybe it's moving
maybe we're looking at furthest down the
line that she ends up there so it kind
of like parallels the other Star Wars
movies do what I don't like about any of
this JJ put this in a movie and had
really no foresight into what it meant
and Ryan has to make something of it no
this is loss though this is lost JJ of
like I'm gonna make some cryptic
cool-looking imagery and we'll figure it
out later
but it means like this is I mean he
loves the whole idea the mystery box in
the first season of the Box lost inside
yeah and lost Yugi you threw polar bears
you threw smoke monsters use your
typewriter sounds in the woods and then
the others and you're like okay there's
a hatch there's a reason and he may have
a reason I think JJ might have been
playing coy and not wanted like he has
been
huge collaborators script
well it's something he's said in an
interview I believe he has watching
because he wanted to be consistent with
the visuals of it and he wanted to maybe
extrapolate on them we'll see I trust
write like Ryan Johnson to me seems like
the best like puzzle assembler like the
guy is looper is such a brilliantly well
thought out I was about to ask what what
the last movie was and yeah that since
that movie has to work in two different
time periods and like figure it out time
yeah he made it he'd figured it out he
figured out in a way that really really
works ah I'm excited to see what he does
with these visuals but let's actually
talk because we're talking about the way
that the past battles in the past
wielders of this weapon and the sound
design doubles down on a really
interesting way in this sequence Abrams
mixed in and Abrams in a sound design
team actually we should credit everybody
worked in lots of bits of audio it's
kind of tough to catch the first time
around but rewatching it should
definitely ring a bell
first the moment ray touches the
lightsaber handle obviously it does the
sound of an admission of a lightsaber
but then as she goes in the quarter we
hear Darth Vader's iconic breathing and
the sound of young race screaming then
we hear the voice of Yoda echoing that
started the line from Empire
energy so it's coming together in a
really so cool way but then next to here
this mysterious roar could be smoke or
kylo Ren it's not really clear what this
is but then you hear the sound of Luke
screaming
[Music]
yeah and it's and that and then during
this we hear yo to complete his line
surrounds us and binds us
but then they repurpose some audio from
Alec Guinness as obi-wan Kenobi this is
the hardest one to catch you hear him
say when you will be tempted and then
they did a really cool theory here
Guinness as obi-wan say Rey and then it
continues as a whisper as she comes out
of this vision and they did this by
mixing both you and McGregor and Alec
Guinness for Guinness they sampled him
say to r2d2 in a new hope it'll be
afraid and they cut out ray and then
they mix it to you in regret they
brought them into an ADR booth and they
just at him whisper into a microphone
all sexy like what do you guys think
like what can we conclude from this does
this tell us anything about oh so far is
the passing of the baton but in the
baton is the light say yeah yeah but
it's I mean with the Skywalker it's a
trilogy and so now we have the next
Skywalker trilogy so it's my mind that
Rey is a Skywalker right and then yeah
these are the first steps and so she's
this is the first time that she's kind
of tapping into it she's she's Harry
Potter all over again you know it's a
poor an orphan child that's making do
with their really crappy life and then
all of a sudden boom they've got in the
inundated with information where it's
like it was so much more than you know
you are yeah and then they slowly kind
of seep into all this information in a
way it kind of it makes the force like
more of a physical place to kind of yeah
it makes it even though it's fun to have
the force ghosts and everything like
that I think this idea of that it like
you tap into some other it's another
thing it's another dimension to what
this universe is and this galaxy where
we're at and the bit I think it's just
more fun than just saying like a ghost
blue ghost walking around right like no
you get to like you get the full memory
of whatever this thing is trying to show
you whatever the force is trying to
teach you wherever you're supposed to go
it's gonna like we've had visuals like
that before I don't know if you noticed
when Luke was undergoing his training on
the
he saw himself wearing Vader's mas oh
yeah so and I I like that you some kind
of impressionistic there's a bit of
surreal imagery I love this design this
is one my favorite scenes I love this
kind of cryptic stuff and I think it
does accurately display what someone who
does not understand what the forces
experienced in it for the first time
it's a collage of different influences
and ghosts and it should feel like a
crazy trippy dream sequence and I
looking forward to seeing more of this
because yeah I think that one shot of
Luke's face in Darth Vader's mask is
probably the most surreal it gets in the
original trilogy and another yeah it is
just voices and force Coast and I I'm
looking forward to seeing like more of
because I feel like the force is such a
dense complicated mysterious thing and I
am as Lucas said it's like poetry and he
was referring to like what Jar Jar
coming back I don't know but I would
like to see a real poetic approach I
think Kyle is going to actually you know
bringing his army he's brought him in
and yet kind of like comment down below
and tweet us at new rock stars like this
video shared around and subscribe to new
rock stars for the deep dives all stuff
you love guys bye Santa
[Music]
Star Trek no check